a man can't peel man hey um you know
what man y'all straight up man
we're doing this a long ass time now
y'all I ain't done and you know
what it's on you now dawg and you know
why I'm gonna tell you right now cuz we
watched this week's episode didn't even
like that you know what it I'm
gonna show the goddamn seeing it where I
want everybody watching this video right
now to see how stupid and up your
scene is so show that goddamn clip
hey there forest now y'all go of a
black hop it's a stupid Swiss tignous me
and everything was taking place at
regular time they should be in a hobbit
village from some celebrity Hardison
that's what they should do put a
celebrity hop it up in there man to play
the black Hobbit man
Webster yeah Webster man with God that's
my jam Webster would have been my
what tinkle
oh Peter Dickel fo Game of Thrones
why don't y'all get that nigga to be in
your that's not soon have been a
funny scene this season y'all
right on up also got a big dick though
ah ha and then he should hair hair on
his feet and a big old hairy bitch how
you gonna have a midget without a big
day singers oh that's Universal I know
how you got the ball on that ha ha ha
midget gotta have a big big man he
should have slugged the business in his
face he should have said nice babysitter
nice pants a bear and slap him in a dick
in the Big Sur huh oh man this little
baby midget made me fart big yeah you're
stupid you know what you know what hey
you know what you dog you
though you know be laughing and
everything but in a true man we laughing
our own cuz I see this gold yeah
but what's up cuz from now on it's gonna
be Huggins and Taylor alright that's the
new show Keeling P cuz we done with
you now man we've done we was trying to
help you out
and I want to take our on the road
and your up a lot of stuff
missing in your show now I don't have
enough in your show the whole
goddamn season one time it's only time
you did it man what I do himself
whenever's want to do that drive on that
one no stop with my
it's been that's the funniest thing they
did all season man want your man how
come you only do that one time then
those dudes should have been in every
show put pants gangsters in the
show that's what I call the same
pants gangster they make up a whole
genre that's what they should call
that's what their name should be too as
you call them pants and fart
drawers
yes yeah Oh speak his name my name is
far drawers then nigga day
this is my partner pants alright
I'm alright - you alright yeah you got a
pretzel marecus shut up hold up man I
got piece of paper right here man
pants and fart drawers and I wished your
niggas were trying to steal that
please tries to and they could put it
put a are with a circle around it
nigga hold up a second man but all with
a circle hold on a second alright
shitpants
yeah alright stop from pants and it
it's part of their name hold up nigga
I'm trying to write some but and
bar draws heart drawers that's on the
wall take that niggas bitch
you